if there is one fundamental truth about
Gamers it's that we're passionate
sometimes to a fault
what was your problem what is your
problem
competitive video games are stressful
when things go awry all that pent-up
energy needs to go somewhere and In the
Heat of the Moment It's usually the
actual developers of the game Who end up
catching Strays I'm so sick of this
[__] company the trash
that's the guy it sucks playing this God
Gaben you suck so much penis at making
video games it [__] hurts me bro
you're watching this [__] with your
[__] very eyes bro this is some
[__] EA Sports you've created this
game in the world usually the anger
subsides you forgive the devs for their
sins and you move on with your deck
sometimes
you don't one Apex Legends Pro recently
found out what happens when you cross
the line and bite the hand that feeds
boy that they're blacklisting Watson
from in the tournaments or something
because that's what happens when you try
to be bigger than a billion dollar
company meet the trash talking king of
Apex aggro Jacob his Watson McMillan who
went from grinding rank to becoming one
of the top players at the professional
level
give me give me behind you
you're it's just you
but his Watson is also known for being
outspoken and at times a little toxic
whether it's towards other Pros or the
actual developers of Apex his Watson
doesn't pull any punches and time and
time again it's landed him in hot water
so how did a kid from the middle of
nowhere become one of the best igls in
the game was he really blacklisted by EA
over his tweets and if he is in fact
using his clout to force them to fix
Apex
is he doing it the right way here is my
new challenge I am going to attempt to
go without drama for one week on Twitter
I know listen it's a big step for me
it's a big step
[Music]
hey folks before we get into the video I
must ever so quickly chill our merch
which is really easy because it is
genuinely awesome we have super comfy
hoodies and t-shirts in cool designs and
you can get some of your own over at
shop.thescore.com okay so before this
sweaty weeb was memeing his way to apex
predator receiving MVP awards and
starting [__] on Twitter his Watson was
just a lonely small town kid with a
dream Watson was obsessed with Shooters
and he really wanted to become a content
creator but it wasn't until he found
Apex legends that he started on his path
to Glory just like Improvement for me is
like really fun you know being the best
at something it's like a really complex
game with like a lot of things going on
so like it always felt like I was
getting better at the game the
competition I expected was really fun
it's not like smaller games where you
played forever you just feel like you
suck for Apex it was like I felt like
there was always something I could
improve on Watson improved rapidly
attending tournaments until he decided
to take a break and grind ranked by May
of 2021 his Watson was streaming Apex
almost every single day and over the
next year he grew respectable following
thanks in part to his incredible skills
foreign
Watson was legitimately one of the best
players in the world in fact he was
literally the best player in the world
at one point in season 11. oh my God
officially
the best player in Apex Legends but with
all of that skill came something else
confidence you see as No Frills and down
to earth as he was Watson was one cocky
son of a gun and nowhere was that more
apparent than on Twitter to put it
plainly his Watson is a bona fide [__]
posting keyboard Warrior whether it's
his contemporaries the Apex Community at
large or even himself Watson beefs with
pretty much everyone and that gave
Watson something of a reputation for
causing drama that said some Esports
teams are willing to play with fire if
it means winning tournaments and it just
so happens that Furia needed some wins
they picked up Watson and almost
immediately qualified for the Apex
Legends Global Series championship and
as you can imagine making it into the
Apex World Championship Gabe Watson
something of an ego boost
as if he needed one for about six months
of that I was a free agent
try to find a tune to play with it
nobody would play with me for some
reason I guess I didn't have tournament
experience and then uh before lcq c-line
who was a friend of mine messaged me
about playing perforia as the igl and at
first I was kind of like man you know
this is a tall order for me I mean
you're asking me to igl I haven't played
comp in Forever even then like I wasn't
the best igl like I was kind of mediocre
like you're asking a lot and then I mean
you know we did really well I just don't
really know how but maybe everybody just
sucks now look Watson is far from the
first [__] talking overconfident Pro
tons of players have been burned in the
past for not being able to back up their
ego on the server sure he'd previously
been rank one in the world but that was
online would he be able to lead his team
to Victory against the best of the best
On Lan and not just any Lan but the algs
championship apex's largest ever
tournament with a two million dollar
prize pool on the line well the fans
didn't have to wait long to find out
gaming But Here Comes the push and
spiritron connects some shots it's one
Johnson his kills for the lips are
things fanatic eliminated Here Comes
Fury they're ready to fight they have
the low ground it's now A.D versus
Furious 100 thieves have fallen big
damage though on to Zara tricky but it
doesn't matter
oh boy oh I gotta do it to them you
gotta do it to them
this man Watson
he's here to meme basically a twitch
troll IRL five knock one Fury gets
another they need to kill points they
need to kill points the turtle 1v1
versus one then he gets shut down once
it says sit the hell down it's fun
oh my God oh my God
oh my God are you kidding me oh my gosh
his Watson can't even believe what he
just did unfortunately after all of the
hard work they put in Furia hit a wall
in the finals despite being on Match
Point for round after round they just
couldn't close it out the Aussies on
dark zero eventually caught up and won
the tournament leaving Furia with a
silver medal that said Furia had plenty
to be proud they shook up the meta had
the most kills and his Watson was named
the tournament MVP for his efforts You
Gotta Give It Up to the New Rising Star
here in Apex Legends now this would be a
perfect spot to end Watson's story a
streamer comes back to Pro play shakes
up the meta gets named MVP at the game's
biggest tournament you couldn't write a
story that perfect but but just Watson
we're talking about once he got back
home from the major he went back on
Twitter to stir up drama but this time
Watson took things to a whole new level
whether he was trolling or being
genuinely outspoken Watson hopped on
Twitter and set his aim on the actual
creators of Apex EA and respawn you see
it's no secret that Apex has its fair
share of problems most notably the sheer
number of hackers plaguing the game fix
it
[__] thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you yeah
let's go let's go all right boys GG Apex
you're [__] finished it's over for
you this game can go suck a [__] you
okay Apex in trash
until this [__] is fixed King trash
plenty of players have complained about
the cheating problem and many believe
that the devs just aren't doing enough
to solve that problem but his Watson is
Far and Away the most vocal yeah like I
died cheaters that play like they would
play for like two or three days and they
just don't get banned because they
played in the AM there's no one to ban
them
and I'm I'm at the point where I don't
even care like all this other stream
sniping me I literally I'm not even
gonna report them because I've reported
people for so long and they just never
got banned like that it would take them
days or weeks to get banned like I'm
just not not gonna do their job for them
anymore and look it's reasonable to want
the game to be better but sometimes he
takes his comments a little too far
especially when they involve one
particular respawn employee Connor
hideouts Ford is a member of the Apex
Legends Security team and part of his
job involves handing out bands to
suspected hackers which is given way to
a lot of arguments between Watson and
hideouts on the Bird app on one
particular occasion Watson flat out told
cheaters when to play since he knew the
security team would be asleep the
argument that followed got so heated
that other community members stepped in
to keep Watson in check but things
really came to a head in September when
a conversation between his Watson and a
known cheater was leaked in the
conversation Watson said that he
personally hated hideouts and wanted to
publicly embarrass both him and yay
shortly after sure Watson tweeted out
that he had been blacklisted from
tournaments by EA and respawn later made
a post condemning the harassment of
their employees like the Bands
uh because I said
because I met a tweet
uh
where I was talking about about a
company
anyways
I can play week two I just can't play
week one anyways it was unclear what
actually triggered the Blacklist and how
long it lasted but it almost didn't
matter the whole controversy sparked a
larger debate about how far one should
go when criticizing a developer although
the community was split on the issue a
ton of high-profile figures considered
Watson to be in the wrong Watson was
dumb about every single thing he ever
did he literally
like basically sent his whole fan base
against hideouts listen facing cheaters
match after match is beyond a pain in
the ass and getting locked out of your
account buy a hacker when your literal
job is to play the game is a massive
issue but starting a personal Vendetta
with an employee
that ain't it look Watson built his
brand around being the smartest and most
talented person in the room that was
gonna lead to drama no matter what
Watson just wasn't ready for the power
that his words and ego could have so the
question is did Watson learn anything
I'm gonna attempt here is my new
challenge
I am going to attempt
to go without drama for one week on
Twitter
I know listen it's a big step for me
it's a big step I mean he still starts
[__] and complains about something
nearly every day but it seems like
specific employees are no longer in his
crosshairs and well progress is progress
Watson seems to be trying his best to
chill out and let his love for the
community shine through he started
giving back to Apex in a really
important way and although he'll
probably never stop trolling he has made
strides towards becoming a less toxic
more well-adjusted member of the scene
guys one more time give it up for your
Monster Energy MVP here's Watson
I drink too much water sounds like a
problem but especially in the evenings
my doctor told me like yeah he just told
me like he's like so the whole thing now
is like you know you have to drink 30
metric tons of water every day drink
when you're thirsty he's like that's the
thing if you're thirsty like drink and
he's like just make sure you drink water
when you're thirsty like don't drink
soda I think people get a little much
now with like the [__] are you are
you hydrated are you hydrating have you
drunk a gallon of water yet right like
it's just like it's a little [__]
like all right chill